so I want to recommend a book first to
everyone here it's called explaining
post-modernism and it's by a gentleman
named Steven Hicks and you need to
understand post-modernism because that's
what you're up against and you're up
against it far more than you know or
think and it's a much more
well-developed and pervasive pernicious
nihilistic intellectually attractive
doctrine than has yet come to public
realization it absolutely dominates the
humanities and increasingly the social
sciences and universities and what's
happening you see someone once said who
unfortunately I can't remember it might
have been Friedrich Nietzsche said that
everybody is the unconscious exponent of
a dead philosopher and fortunately the
post modern philosophers most of them
are dead so that's a good thing but that
doesn't mean that their words aren't
continually being spoken by people who
who are following in their wake like
saying it's not like any given person is
absolutely possessed and saved by the
spirit of post-modernism because often
they're not educated enough to know all
the details about what it is that has
them in their grip but if you get 20 of
them together and they're all 5%
influenced by the post modernist ethos
you basically have the spirit of the mob
that's a mouthpiece for that particular
philosophical doctrine and if you
understand the doctrine then you
understand why things are progressing
the way that they're progressing and so
I'm going to tell you a little bit about
the doctrine because it's not optional
to understand this it's absolutely
crucial to understand this huh you can't
underestimate the power of ideas and
also the power of words of course
because ideas are expressed in words but
you see the post modernists completely
reject the structure of Western
civilization and I mean completely so I
can give you an example in one term
Jacques Derrida whose head trickster for
the post modernist movement regarded
Western culture let's call it the
patriarchy as a logo centric okay so
fallow comes from phallus PHA ll oh and
so that's the insistence that what you
see in Western culture is the constant
of a male-dominated oppressive
self-serving society and we might say
well you know societies do tend to be
self-serving and people in power do tend
to act in their best interests but a
tendency is not an absolute and that's
one of the things that needs to be
considered continually there are no
shortage of flaws in the manner in which
we've structured our society and
compared to any hypothetical utopia it's
and that's absolutely dismal wreck but
compared to the rest of the world and
the plight of other societies throughout
the history of mankind we're doing
pretty damn well and we should be happy
to be living in the society that we're
living in so the first thing that you
might want to note about post-modernism
is that it doesn't have a shred of
gratitude and there's something
tautologically wrong with the person who
does that it doesn't have any gratitude
especially when they live in what so far
is the best of all possible worlds and
so if you're not grateful you're driven
by resentment and resentment is the both
the worst emotion that you can possibly
experience apart from arrogance
resentment arrogance and deceit there is
an evil triad for you and if you're
bitter about everything that's happening
around you despite the fact that you're
bathed in wealth and there's something
absolutely wrong with you you know the
black community in the United States is
the 18th wealthiest community 18th
wealthiest nation on the planet now that
doesn't mean there isn't such a thing as
relative poverty and relative poverty
matters it's an important it's an
important political economic issue and
it's very very difficult to deal with
but absolute wealth matters too and the
Western societies have been absolutely
remarkable in their ability to generate
and distribute wealth as you can tell by
just looking around and taking a you
know a brief bit of consideration for
the absolute miracle that even a
building like this represents so you
have to educate yourself about
post-modernism ok so here's what the
post modernists believe they don't
believe in the individual that's the
logos Park Western culture is fel logo
centric logo is logos that's partly the
Christian word but it's also partly the
root word of logic ok they don't believe
in logic they believe that logic is part
of the process by which the patriarchal
institutions of the West continue to
dominate and to justify their dominance
they don't believe in dialogue the
word of dialogue is logos again they
don't believe that people of goodwill
can come to consensus through the X
through the exchange of ideas they
believe that that notion is part of the
philosophical substructure and practices
of the dominant culture so the reason
they don't let people who they don't
agree with speak on campuses because
they don't agree with letting people
speak you see it's not part of the ethos
ok so what else do they believe and not
believe they believe that you since you
don't have an individual identity your
fundamental identity is Group fostered
and that means that you're basically an
exemplar of your race hence white
privilege or you're an exemplar of your
gender or your sex or your ethnicity or
you're an exemplar of however you can be
classified so that use you are placed in
the position of victim against the
oppressor because that's the game and
it's it's a it's a post Marxist
sleight-of-hand right the old Marxist
notion was that the world was a
battleground between the burgeois Z and
the proletariat and that failed to have
any philosophical or ethical standing
that argument after the working class
actually saw its standard of living
massively elevated as a consequence of
Western corporate democracy Western free
enterprise democracy and also the end
and also as a consequence of the
revelations of everything terrible that
had happened in every bloody country
that ever dared to make equity and and
the Marxist communist Dogma part of
their fundamental structure right and
nothing but murderous nozanne depression
and so by the 1970s it was evident that
that game was up the postmark the post
modernist Marxist just barely basically
pulled a sleight of hand and said ok if
it's not the poor against the rich it's
the oppressed against the oppressor will
just read of I'd the subpopulations in
ways that make our our bloody philosophy
continuing it's in its in its movement
forward and that's where we're at now
and so for the post modernists the world
is a Hobbesian battleground of identity
groups they do not communicate with one
another because they can't all there is
is a struggle for power and if you're in
the predator group which means you're an
oppressor then you better look out
because you're not exactly well
come not exactly welcome and neither are
your ideas so that's what you're up
against I would say it's time for
conservatives to stop apologizing for
being conservatives no and you don't
apologize to these people that's a big
mistake apology there they read apology
as an admission of guilt you don't
apologize and you don't back down you
young people that are out there who are
University students you need to take
over the student unions you need to take
them back because they're absolute snake
pits and they have been since the 1990s
with regards with regards to the
universities I thought at one point that
the best thing to do would be to cut
their funding by 25 percent let them
fight amongst themselves for the
remnants because it would force the
universities to decide exactly what's
important and what isn't so I would say
the humanities and much of the social
sciences has turned into a postmodern
neo-marxist playground for radicals the
scholarship is terrible
80% of humanities papers aren't cited
once once and so what that means is that
they write papers for each other and
they sell them to libraries and that's
how the publishers make their money no
one reads them but the publishers can
print them because the libraries have to
buy them and they're buying them with
your tax money and so all of you who are
sitting here are funding a postmodern
radical neo-marxist agenda that has its
roots in the university and your tax
money is going towards that and if you
want proof of that you just go online
and look at the websites especially of
disciplines like women's studies which
is pathological right to the core but
it's not just women's studies it's all
the ethnic studies groups
it's anthropology its sociology its
social work and most of all it's
education and oszi for example in
Ontario is perhaps apart from the
Ontario Human Rights Commission the most
dangerous institution in Canada it
should
it should be defunded it's as simple as
that they don't do the research they
purport to do they're not interested in
it at all in education they're
interested in the indoctrination of
people as young as they can fun as young
as they can get their hands on so to
speak now we need to figure out our
society needs to figure out how to stop
shunting public tax money to radical
left-wing activists if we were doing
that for radical right-wing activists
there would be an absolute storm but
it's happened incrementally since the
1960s and it needs to stop so that's
that's partly what the Conservatives not
only conservatives but also liberals
true liberals in the English sense are
up against I mean what's happened that
as also as a consequence of this
postmodern neo-marxist intellectual
invasion is that the center keeps moving
it's moved way to the right now so if
you're a classic liberal you've become a
conservative and so for all of you who
are interested in Purdue pursuing the
conservative agenda there's a lot of
classic liberals that you could be
talking to and then finally with regards
to talking to young people you finally
have something to sell to them you know
it's not easy to sell conservatism to
young people because they want to change
things and that's not what conservatives
want to do they want to maintain things
well now you've got something to sell
the young people you can sell them
freedom of speech and you can tell sell
them responsibility the left is selling
them rights you can sell the
responsibility and I can tell you
because I received many letters of the
sort that that God was talking about
young people are absolutely starving
for someone to provide them with the
sense of responsibility and say look
here's something worth living for man
you know you can find meaning in life
with freedom but freedom freedom is a
chaotic sort of meaning right and
freedom isn't the sort of thing that
makes people happy it's the sort of
thing that makes people trouble some
trouble because freedom expands your
your series of choices and that makes
you nervous and uncertain so but
responsibility is another and not to say
that that's a bad thing it's a good
thing but it requires that you that you
shoulder the responsibility of the
freedom but responsibility per se is
what gives your life meaning genuine
meaning in the face of suffering and you
and young people is really there
starving for that I've been teaching
young people for thirty years and mostly
what I've been teaching them about is
responsibility it's like your heirs to a
great tradition it's not perfect
obviously but comparatively there's
nothing else like it that's ever been
produced and it's it represents a tiny
minority of human qualities most of
which are run by murderous antisocial
psychopathic thugs and not that
seriously and so what kind of
alternative is that we've got this
beacon of freedom and wealth in the West
that works although it doesn't work
perfectly and one of the one of the
responsibilities of young people is to
find out what's at the core of that the
great great core of that the paramount
the paramount importance of the
individual and the divinity of speech
man not some to sell its what our whole
culture is predicated on
all right well I should stop there so
thank you very much for the invitation
[Applause]